intentemos restar números de dos dígitos
aquí tenemos 65 23 y te invito a que
pongas pausa al vídeo a que lo intentes
ahora como me gusta hacerlo yo inicio
primero con las unidades
los números en lugar de las unidades los
puse en color amarillo estas son las
unidades
los números en morado son las decenas
entonces estas son las decenas así que
unidades están en amarillo y decenas en
morado lo que puedo hacer es poner
columnas entonces bueno donde donde todo
lo que esté en amarillo en esta columna
amarilla esas son las unidades
representa las unidades y la columna en
color morado representa las decenas en
lugar de las decenas entonces bueno eso
ya está ahora 65 es lo mismo que 6
decenas y 5 unidades 23 es lo mismo que
dos decenas y tres unidades para
resolver esto lo que podemos hacer es
enfocarnos primero en las unidades
entonces cinco unidades menos tres
unidades eso es igual a dos unidades y
después enfocarnos en las decenas seis
decenas menos dos decenas es cuatro
decenas o lo que es lo mismo
42 ahora bien yo puedo escribir esto de
distintas maneras por ejemplo lo que
puedo hacer es escribir el 65 lo puedo
representar como seis decenas más cinco
unidades esos sesenta y cinco seis
decenas más cinco unidades
ahora a esto yo le estoy restando 23
entonces como estoy restando 23 estoy
restando 2 decenas y luego restando 3
unidades también baja entonces pongo
menos dos decenas
y después resto tres unidades pongo aquí
menos tres unidades ahora esto a qué
equivale bueno veamos vamos a analizar
esto cinco unidades tengo cinco unidades
menos tres unidades eso es igual a dos
unidades
y ahora vamos con las decenas seis
decenas menos dos decenas eso es igual a
cuatro decenas así que he escrito de
esta manera lo que tenemos es cuatro
decenas más dos unidades o lo que es lo
mismo 42 65 menos 23 es igual a 42 y 42
es exactamente lo mismo que cuatro
decenas más dos unidades o seis decenas
más cinco unidades menos dos decenas
menos tres unidades es cuatro decenas
más dos unidades y ya terminamos